معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري نجوان ما الذي رصدته من حيث تتواجدين
لتطور المعارك في قطاع غزه تحديدا على
الجبهه
الشرقيه نعم نحن غنو نقف في محاذاه
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه تحديدا منطقتي
بيت حانون
وجباليا عفوا و بيت لاهيه وهذا اليوم يعني
رصدنا ربما وتيره اقل من السابق لعمليات
قصف لكن في بعض الاحيان تسمع اشتباكات
بالرشاشات الثقيله تحديدا من منطقه بيت
لاهيه غرب بيت حنون
و الصوت الوحيد ربما الذي لا يتوقف هنا هو
اصوات لانفجارات عنيفه في المناطق
الشماليه والمناطق الشرقيه ايضا لقطاع غزه
طيله الوقت هناك دوي لهذه ال الانفجارات
وهي جراء عمليات تفجير واسعه يجريها سلاح
الهندسه في الجيش الاسرائيلي ل مبان
وابراج
و عده منازل هو يقول بانه يقوم بتفجير
البنى التحتيه والانفاق لحركات المقاومه
لحركه حماس تحديدا لكن من الواضح وفقا
للكثير من مقاطع الفيديو التي تبث اي
ويبثها جنود في داخل ال
الميدان نشاهد بانهم يقومون بتفجير مبان
سكنيه ومنازل لسكان فلسطينيين ربما لعدم
السماح لاي من سكان هذه المناطق ب من
العوده لتلك ال المناطق لكن فيما عدا ذلك
كان قد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي على لسان
الناطق العسكري وايضا على لسان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوم امس بان هذه
المناطق من منطقه بيت حانون وبيت لاهيه
وصولا الى منطقه وادي غزه جنوب مدينه غزه
تم الانتقال فيها الى المرحله التاليه في
هذه الحرب وهي عباره عن تحويل القتال الى
مداهمات محدوده ومحدده الاهداف واعاده
تموضع للقوات واعاده انتشار للقوات بمعنى
انسحاب من موا من محاور توغلت فيها سابقا
هذه قوات في حين انه يؤكد بان العمليات
الواسعه والقص وعمليات القصف ايضا مستمره
في مناطق الوسط في مخيمات الوسط في قطاع
غزه وايضا في منطقه الجنوب في خان يونس
تحديدا هناك يقول بانه يواصل توسيع وتعميق
عملياته البريه لكن هذا اليوم كان هناك
اعلان عن مقتل تسعه من الضباط والجنود في
الجيش الاسرائيلي يوم امس في يوم وصفت فيه
المعارك بانها كانت الاقصى او اليوم
الاقصى على الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ عده
اسابيع منذ بدايه العمليات البريه لاسما
وان سته من بين الضباط والجنود قتلوا في
انفجار لشاحنه عسكريه كانت تحوي الكثير من
المواد المتفجره والذخيره كانت بهدف تفخيخ
بنى تحتيه وانفاق في من منطقه مخيم البريج
وتفجرت في الجنود من غير الواضح بعد او
على الاقل لم يعلن بعد من الجانب
الاسرائيلي كيف تفجرت هذه الشاحنه هل كان
الانفجار جراء استهداف من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه او انه حادث هناك من يشير الى
هذا الاتجاه وهناك من يحاول ان يقول بانه
انفجار داخلي لكن هناك تحقيقات بدا يجريها
الجيش لا سما وان اربعه من بين الجنود
الذين قتلوا في هذه الحادثه هم من وحده
النخبه وحده لام في سلاح الهندسه
الاسرائيلي هذا بالاضافه الى ما نشره موقع
والله العبري انه في هذه الحادثه فقط اصيب
ما لا يقل عن 30 ضابطا وجنديا وصفت جروح
عدد منهم بال خطيره جراء هذا الانفجار في
هذا الموقع بالاضافه الى ذلك كانت هناك
حوادث ووقائع اخرى في منطقه خان يونس
اثنان من الجنود قتلا جراء استهدافهم
بصاروخ مضاد للدروع في منطقه خان يونس
بالاضافه الى جندي اخر قتل في اشتباكات مع
المقاومين الفلسطينيين اذا تسعه من الجيش
الاسرائيلي من قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي في
داخل غزه قتلوا في يوم واحد وهو بطبيعه
الحال عدد كبير بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيلي
وهي خسائر يتكبدها الجيش يوميا من اصابات
ومن قت
هو نشر الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي هذا
اليوم عن 27 اصابه خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه لكنها عمليا تختلف كليا هذه
المعطيات عما نشر في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه اذ انه يتحدث عن 27 جنديا
اصيب من بينهم سبعه بحاله خطره في مجمل
المعارك التي دارت في غزه يوم امس لكن من
جهه اخرى راينا انه في موقع والله العبري
تحدث المراسل العسكري عن اصابه 30 جنديا
وضابطا في حادثه الانفجار وحدها
وبالتالي طيلت الوقت غنو هذا الفارق بين
المعطيات والارقام يثير الكثير من
التساؤلات و لماذا يواصل الجيش الاسرائيلي
باخفاء بعض المعلومات المتعلقه تحديدا ب
عدد جرحاه في اي غزه لكن هناك نوع من ال
يعني الصدمه في الشارع الاسرائيلي ان صح
التعبير ايه في ما يتعلق بهذه الاعداد
التي اخذ بالازدياد وهذا ما كتب عنه اليوم
احد الكتاب البارزين في دعوت احرونوت ناح
برنيه الذي تحدث بان بانه يجب الخروج من
هذا البئر وفقا لتعبيره يجب انهاء هذه
الحرب قبل تكبد المزيد من الخسائر في صفوف
الجيش شكرا لك من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري